la fin après quarante jours de
confinement volontaire quinze personnes
vont bientôt sortir d'une grotte en
ariège l'objectif étudier le
comportement humain en l'absence de
repères spatio-temporels cette
expérience scientifique n'est pas
nouvelle le pionnier du confinement
volontaire c'est lui cet homme c'est le
commencement d'une terrible expérience
il s'appelle michel siffre il a 23 ans
il a décidé de passer deux mois sous
terre par 130 mètres de fond michel
siffre profession explorateurs
scientifique ou encore spéléologues le
17 juillet 1962 il se terre au fond du
gouffre de skara sont en italie
le but observez comment le corps humain
réagit en l'absence de cycle jour nuit
seule sa descente et sa remontée ont été
filmés et le 14 septembre 1962 après
deux mois sous terre
il en ressort épuisé la peur je commence
à être saturé la peur maintenant et
pendant je me calme et un peu quelqu'un
quelques mois après cette expérience
michel siffre aumessas dix ans plus tard
cette fois direction les états unis et
la mine à kiev au texas
quelques minutes avant de descendre le
scientifique expliquer les raisons de
cette opération c'est qu'on peut retirer
de cette expérience c'est une réelle
connaissance des mécanismes du sommeil
et surtout une meilleure connaissance de
ces mécanismes du sommeil qui provoque
la fatigue humaine lorsqu'on franchit
des fuseaux horaires angel l'expérience
débute le 14 février 1972
michel siffre s'engouffre seul à 30
mètres de profondeur
là aussi sans aucun repères
spatio-temporels avant de dormir
le scientifique se soumet à toute une
batterie de tests physiques
le reste de la journée il s'occupe comme
il peut j'écris un général parfois je ne
fais rien je pense ça m'arrive très
souvent le matin assis à ma table de
travail est souvent j'ai décidé donc je
vais note et je prépare le futur
mon futur mes expériences ou mes
expéditions futur pour communiquer avec
la surface michel siffre utilise une
ligne téléphonique 30 mètres plus haut
trois hommes seraient les jour et nuit
pour contrôler les opérations
être en constamment devant les
appareillages électronique pour
l'enregistrement de mes nuits
toute la journée pour l'enregistrement
du coeur et de la température enfin un
travail dément le 5 septembre 1972 après
200 jours confinés soit près de sept
mois
michel siffre ressort plus en forme que
la première fois les années plus tard en
1999 le scientifique descendre à une
troisième fois sous terre 69 jours au
total
au fond de la grotte de clamouse dans
l'hérault
[Musique]